you would think because I've been
watching like obviously this year there
was a
the guy who I can't stand right now
because of how he's treated my sons is
Patrick Beverly because he he got at
your guy CP in the back and then earlier
this year he laid at eight now I like
Pat Ben though I just I don't like
everything he does and I don't have to
he says some pretty crazy [__] too yeah
yeah he sets him out he says some
outlandish no it wasn't really to me it
was to to CP you know and and I'm just
thinking like I just didn't like I feel
like media
now it's so it's less about you know
kind of covering what we're watching and
critiquing and it's more just about
being disrespectful exactly I just don't
like that you know I mean I feel like if
you know the game there's so much more
you can talk about than being just
straight disrespectful and it's tough
because we do have to critique
especially for more players we have to
critique people we played with before of
course and that's part of the job but I
feel like you can critique without being
disrespectful yeah and I just think now
I mean that you see guys like Skip
Bayless he's tripping right now and you
know Stephen A Smith has his runs and I
just feel like guys like are so
disrespectful now that players coming in
think they kind of have to they have to
like one up the guys carry that type of
energy but we don't because we really
lived it I mean these dudes that are out
here doing whatever they do and I
respect everyone in their language the
talking heads are different than the
former players oh man we have a
different we have a we have a natural
leg up right we really live this you
know what I mean so I just didn't like
the way and and the crazy part was like
when we had our little back and forth
like this shit's all about ratings you
know I mean ESPN loves it he was on TV
like the next six six days yeah they put
him on and he has stuff to say like I
think he's gonna be good at it when he
gets done I just you know what like his
you know like come on man we don't need
that company you know the way he was
talking about Chris and then like I
think it's obvious there's like a
personal Vendetta there I mean we can go
back that's fine and it can be that's
right right right right though unless
you guys are really gonna fight and to
me that's and to me that's where someone
like who I I loved seeing Paul Pierce on
TV but sometimes anytime LeBron would
get brought up you would just be like
okay we get it bro like we get it like
you don't [__] with LeBron it's the
first it's the personal stuff you know
what I mean and it's just naturally as
competitors that's just how we are but I
mean if you're gonna be on TV and and
really do what you know what would you
have the capability of doing you can't
be you can be biased in kind of like a
cool or a funny way but you can't be
biased in a hater way exactly you can't
be a hater you can't be a hater that's
some real [__] because it's just you
know look at the old head hey like I I
just don't like
I mean this is a whole nother Direction
even going but like kind of like former
players that feel like they have to
disrespect the guys that are playing now
it happens a lot and it just kind of
respect the evolution you know I mean I
get the money's crazy high and some of
these guys never gonna say man don't
deserve the money but you know some of
these guys get paid a ton of money and
don't put up the numbers that some of
the older dudes to get up Do by a long
shot and they're getting paid and and
and you know again I think it's one of
those situations where we have to
critique that's our job but I think you
can you know just leave the hate out
like there's just no room for you to me
you always want to love and push it
encourage the Next Generation to
continue to be greater and continuing to
raise the bar and if you're going to
critique somebody critique them from a
place of like if they see that they
might be able to take something from
that and yeah constructive criticism
because it's all about yeah being
constructed because otherwise you're
being a dick like really help these
young dudes out on and off the court I
feel like they can do you know I mean
especially some of these legends that
are that are on TV and I'm not saying
all you know all they do is disrespect
but there's times where I'm saying like
damn bro you used to play a player how
you gonna say some [__] like that you
know what I mean but it's like you know
I think that the only guy who like
I'm not everyone looks the other way on
because guys like KD and there's been a
lot of people but I just feel like
Charles Barkley is in a space in his own
where Barclay can just just he just Shaq
might get some [__] but Charles doesn't
give a [__] what you think Charles don't
give a [__] and I think and I love him
it's just a part of the culture now I
don't always agree with Charles but I
love the man [__] this is me well I
think also Chuck's been doing that job
for like 20 25 years now so like he's
his NBA career has almost
his broadcasting career is almost as
great as some people only know him as
that's what I mean broadcaster you know
and but the one thing I love about him
is he's always been as a player he was
this way this is me yeah take it or
leave it yeah I mean so I always you
know respect Chuck but again he's one of
the you know people in the spaces where
when you know
I think someone like you do you give him
a pass because it's Chuck yeah I mean I
think he kind of did him and I feel yeah
kind of gets a passive people be on
Shaq's ass too but I mean a shack like
what can you really say to Shaq you know
what I mean so I think there's a few
guys that are just like
they gonna do what they're gonna do 100
it's not always hating but it's just you
know sometimes some some crazy [__] come
out their mouth but I mean outside of
that I just think you know we should
always try it again critique but make it
constructive Peterson something they can
add to their life into their game